foreign
guys like to hear a freestyle rap about
lost in the woods on an RV
lost in why was that so quick it was
immediately lost in the woods on an RV
trip Chris that's the night dream in my
life has been for a White English guy to
say what do you want to rap about and
I'll be prepared with a hyper-specific
event from my childhood
lost in the woods on an RV trip okay
this corner over here suggestion number
two What's it gonna be
spotted spotted dick now for those of
you who don't know
that is a it's a British dessert I
suppose
um not a sexually transmitted disease
it's uh it's it's it's a bread pudding
dotted with raisins and currants
commonly served with custard uh yeah
that it's disgusting
um if someone offers you spotted dick
hope they're gonna reach for their groin
not the pastry cabinet middle of the
room so far we've got those two what's
yours gonna be
generational trauma and there was a
family of people saying it
generational trauma do you do you have a
specific example of it something that
you considering
somebody just give us one
[Applause]
okay well we'll have to imagine it
um
this corner over here
okay so you said something about pissing
in the snow
making artwork by pissing in the snow
and you said my daughter in Cancun for
for spring break
my daughter is 18 months old by the time
that reaches Cancun will be beneath the
sea it is I'm just like come on sea
level rise
in it like no you chose Cancun you chose
Cancun um and then I mean we've got five
already but I don't want you guys to
miss out there's a you just put a hand
up very politely yes what would you like
a rapper
slugs
[__] have you ever have you ever seen
slugs [__]
it's pretty it's pretty crazy okay
spotted dick getting lost in the woods
on an RV trip generational trauma making
artwork by pissing in the snow and uh my
daughter in Cancun on spring break well
uh okay do me a favor DJ drop that beat
this is yeah this is really happening
we're doing this
as I said it is a freestyle rap this is
made up this isn't prepared this isn't
rehearsed I didn't tell this guy to sit
here and come out with some weird
Twisted [__] it's gonna be delightful
it's gonna be better than you expecting
it to be and we'll start with the food
one that seems simplest then we'll
progress and enjoy ourselves
six suggestions a lot to fit in gotta to
be quick I wanna fill my belly getting
all the spotted dick not like a gay guy
with the syphilis talking about the
bread cake since I was a little kid I
was getting all the custards making sure
it's served freshly hot mix it up by
birds that's the name of the brand only
Brits understand spotted dick the worst
food in our land I prefer maybe Philly
cheesecake is what you serve over here
made the mistake you were going there to
the woods saying I hope my family
holiday goes good but sadly nah you got
lost you like Mom Dad yourself you
crossed praying on your knees Jesus
would lead you out the woods to the RV
camp in Leeds too but yeah get trapped
in a bear's Lair walking in there like
[__] I don't care your rummage looking
for the bread crumbs you put on the
floor and the spotted dig you drop more
and more but sadly the birds cane should
have warned you it lingered round
generational trauma you were paying lots
of cash 150 to psychotherapy a piss kind
of Shifty but my ladies at the back you
said it with Brio like three of you at
one time ladies in the trio when I was
younger I saw my dad drink so much oh my
gosh it makes me sad really just come to
your senses how does this make sense how
does it offend and maybe you could go
forget yourself going off to Cancun and
take a bit of wealth make it rain at the
bar spend it a lot see a nice Mexican
guy he'll buy shots and if you're there
uh yeah you really ought to keep an eye
out for my now 18 year old daughter she
can't really drink she's underage it
would be under the ocean by that stage
you'll be drinking from morning to
afternoon not in Atlantic City in
[__] Cancun and what she doing she's
gonna go berserk she's gonna start
pissing making all the artwork not in
Cancun because the snow doesn't fall
maybe Colorado climbing having balls
will not actually the scrotal area she
needs to urinate she's aware for sure
she's like piss piss piss urinate all
day
you can spell your name
your name it's easier for boys we can
aim our penis ladies your artwork's less
hot you've got to aim the frame and so
you just squat you try and do something
out the back you just pointed it and say
that's abstract anyway
I'm really trying when I piss on playing
air like the impressionist the last
thing I really want a warm hug from the
loving animal I see the garden slug is
small and gray it's got that antenny too
many it sees the others and it's like I
might befriend these one thing you need
to know tonight slugs not males or
female they're hermaphrodites that means
they've got both sex organs it needs the
sex with the Slugs so rewarding they
start to swirl round there tail to the
head like an aura Barossa tiny little
blue egg forms in the middle I've seen
it happen in the wild it gave me
generational trauma as a child happy
going there it's not fine I wish I could
travel back and Rewind a little image of
the slug seed in my mind head to tail
slot [__] that's a 69.
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
you guys are delightful my name is Chris
Turner thank you very much